the kindling the material that is burst
into flame in Syria or Egypt or Libya
Tunisia they're all different cases but
the spark that when one one to the other
was common hi I'm Matt Welch here in Las
Vegas Nevada at the Freedom Fest
conference and I'm joined this morning
with Tom Palmer the executive
something-or-other at the Atlas Network
he also works with Cato tell us a little
bit for the people who don't know about
the Atlas Network what it's do yeah it
was the Economic Research Foundation
also known as the Atlas network.org
works with about 400 think-tanks
worldwide and helping people to found
them bringing together the various
constituents scholars journalists
students business people to promote
Liberty in their particular country or
context and helping them to run them as
businesses we work with dreamers and
idealists and thinkers and then we have
to say well at the same time a
think-tank is a business you need good
accounting good governance transparency
measurements of effectiveness that sort
of work we do so you're interested in
freedom in a global context I think in
many ways the most interesting story in
2011 is what's happening in the Arab
Middle East and North Africa a lot of
different kind of takes on that what
does it mean is it a sort of liberal
movement that hard is it a kind of
Muslim nationalism counter-reaction
give us kind of a big periscope picture
your assessments of what that is how you
know should we feel enthusiastic or
optimistic about it what do you think
I'm modestly optimistic I think good
things are likely to come of this but
obviously it's a complicated case a few
things to be kept in mind every country
is different so the kindling the
material that is burst into flame in
Syria or Egypt or Libya Tunisia they're
all different cases but this spark that
when one one to the other was common and
it started on December 16th of last year
young man and then the Tariq al fayeed
Mohamed Bouazizi did something very
simple he borrowed $200 to be able to
buy fruits and vegetables for his stand
next morning to be able to go out and do
business trying to make a living
at about 10:30 the next morning he was
assaulted by the local police and a
government official they said he didn't
have a license they overturned his
vegetable card they destroyed his
produce he was slapped publicly and
humiliated and they took his electronic
scales this is a little humiliation
having to live under this lawless kind
of regime which is the way most Arabs
live under unaccountable governments
that are corrupt and brutal and he went
to the governor's office and he said I
want my scales back I can't do business
without being able to measure how much
the customers is buying and no one
listened to him no one looked at him he
was ignored he went out into the street
and he said if you don't see me I'll
burn myself an almost inconceivable act
of protest
it's a horrible act of desperation by
state arson he went to the petrol
station petrol and before he lit himself
on fire he said how is a man to make a
living
and did this this horrible act it
outraged people in Tunisia that they
said we have to live like this
he died on January 4th his sister went
talk to the reuters said imagine what
would cause a man to do such a thing
we have no dignity in our town in city
busey if you don't have connections or
money to pay bribes you have no dignity
in life and this call for basic human
dignity went from country to country so
we don't want to re-roll by autocrats
who are presidents for life and then
appoint their sons to succeed them it's
been a movement of astonishing courage
and bravery in most countries
substantially nonviolent at least on the
part of the protesters not too far down
the government and it has shown a demand
for dignity I think that is the most
important element of this the Islamists
the radical Islamists were caught
unawares as were the autocrats they of
course then rein his face as they could
after a while to get in front of the
parade to claim somehow they're leading
it but it didn't fool anyone
certainly in Egypt a big case that
people are focused on the Muslim
Brotherhood was shocked and surprised
they were not initially supportive of it
they then came out in support of it but
they're fracturing now they're breaking
apart into different factions some of
which are more friendly to the classical
liberal values and some of them are
adamantly opposed I think it's a healthy
thing that they're breaking up as to
what's going to happen it's hard to say
in each country is unique Egypt is the
big one if you will and there you have
many different players and those notably
the military who own maybe 20% of the
economy military socialism and they will
fight to retain their privilege the
forces of Liberty are very active we
work with them really brave and
courageous people in each country and
part of my job is to enable them to work
with their other friends around the
world we have a project minbar alpha org
the forum of Liberty in Arabic we do
programs all over the Arab world this
week we have a seminar in Morocco in
Arabic the summer school on freedom
we'll do one in Egypt and we're really
ramping up with our partners in the Arab
world so I'm excited and modestly
optimistic from your perspective what is
the proper either American u.s. foreign
policy response to this or even like a
an American way of thinking about it and
it because the two are a little bit
intertwined I think that the wise
approach in the US government is to
learn to shut up and keep their hands to
themselves they find it very difficult
to do that even on the level of rhetoric
we had first the Obama administration
think well we're behind Mubarak and were
for stability and then well maybe he's
being too harsh and maybe maybe things
should change and at the end they
claimed credit for the whole thing we
were behind it from the beginning which
of course discredited many of the people
who had been promoting it to be
portrayed by our Secretary of State is
some kind of puppets of the US this was
really it was false and it was stupid
they should learn to shut up but as we
know politicians find this extremely
difficult to just keep their mouth shut
and keep their hands to themselves I
don't think that military intervention
is wise in that situation let them sort
these things out from the perspective of
Americans we should try to do something
it's hard to do imagine what it's like
to be another person
one of the hardest human acts there is
but it's a foundation of libertarian
values but if I were that person would I
like being treated like that and to
understand people who have lived under
one-party dictatorship state control of
the media like in Syria what their life
is like what it is that they're trying
to achieve they don't hate us because we
chew gum or drink alcohol a small number
do the average person is generally
pretty well disposed toward Americans
they resent our governments intervention
into Middle Eastern affairs this is
undeniable that the US has been very
involved in the Middle East and soft
times in very unpopular ways that's
generally resented by most people but
they don't have a burning hatred of the
United States and also to try to
understand Islam as a religion that has
been caricatured as inherently violent
I'm not going to say it's true or false
because I don't tell other people what
their religions mean but I know the vast
majority of Muslims reject that and many
Muslim libertarians actively work for
religious freedom for toleration and
coexistence let's find our friends
they're the best friends we can have are
the libertarians in Syria in Jordan
Lebanon Egypt and other countries in the
region and work with them final question
the morality of capitalism what your
professor won't tell you what is this
about what do you doing well actually
it's a project with Atlas and the
students for Liberty which is a great
organization and these students watching
this should go to students live before
Liberty org I'm a big fan we are
producing 100,000 copies of a book on
the morality of capitalism and it has
chapters by business people by scholars
chapters translated from Chinese and
Russian high school student can read it
up
The Economist's can read it a
businessperson can read it and get
something out of it we wanted to focus
on is the the moral foundation of a free
market economy it's morally good it's
just people who make money honestly in
the market don't have to pay back to
society that's why they're rich they
gave something to other people in a real
free market as opposed to cronyism which
unfortunately is the direction we're
moving toward now crony capitalism
that's great thank you very much thank
you for recent TV I'm Matt Welch